en plein coeur de paris la station de
métro saint paul pas saint-androny saint
patrick saint paul ça fait plus de
trente ans que peter hewlett a posé le
pied en france pourtant à voir son look
on pourrait se croire dans les highlands
[Musique]
la berne night c'est l'occasion pour les
écossais d'honorer tous les 25 janvier
depuis 200 ans la mémoire du poète
robert burns alias le barde c'est comme
si nous fêtions chez nous la nuit
rabelais et que ce soit dans un pub à
paris ou dans une soirée privée à
neuilly les écossais en profite pour
sortir leurs instruments
il yad'autres sorte de cornemuse la
plupart d'entre elles sont beaucoup plus
petite que celle là cet instrument
s'appelle la grande cornemuse des
highlands
c'est un vieux modèle de cornemuse qu'on
utilisait il ya des centaines d'années
dans les highlands en écosse
on quitte le new world alliance pub
écossais dans le marais pour une
banlieue très chic de la capitale à
neuilly dans cet hôtel 4 étoiles on
célèbre aussi la bernstein
mais ici ce n'est pas la même ambiance
qu'il te bien pisser et robes de soirée
dans le rôle du maître de cérémonie
georges match le président de la
calédonienne society of france parfait
vous savez vous êtes et marama soir on
va s'asseoir désolé
d'interrogation à yu qingtai
un des invités ce soir c'est xavier lui
et antillais d'origine écossaise et bien
sûr il porte le fameuse kindu un couteau
traditionnel qui servait autrefois à
occire les anglais ce qu'est ce que ça
veut dire aux gars et les petits
couteaux noir on disait généralement que
c'était pour aider les anglais mais la
manière la moins efficace plusieurs bons
en général c'est plutôt un couteau qui
permet de tout permet en fait de
d'agrémenter la tenue et de la rendre un
peu plus élégante tout simplement au pub
david le barman joue lui aussi du
couteau mais ici les choses sont un peu
plus sérieuse
alors c'est quoi
c'est pas un skin du mois c'est un
couteau de chasse un des invités la
porte parce qu'il est dans l'armée c'est
un couteau militaire
ça ressemble au couteau de rambo ça
parfaitement règle numéro une qu'elle
soit bien des ou plus populaire la bern
ce night débute par un bénédicité
certains de la viande mais ne peuvent
pas manger certains voudraient manger
mais ne le peuvent pas mais nous avons
de la viande et nous pouvons manger loué
soit seigneur vient ensuite le moment où
il faut rendre à berne ce qui lui
appartient c'est à dire son poème il est
récité ou plutôt déclamé en dialecte
écossais comme le veut la tradition
même chose au pub mais cette fois en
français dans le texte du règne sur tout
non justement
du mérite à l'hommage plus grand que mon
bras dans le vi est un texte mais
rabelaisien donc c'est quand même très
proche de la culture française
c'est une heure de la bonne bouffe si en
france on peut pas faire une ode à la
bonne bouffe
le cadeau bonus de la soirée c'est la
panse de brebis farcie au foie poumon et
coeur de moutons on rajoute de l'avoine
et pas question de faire la fine bouche
bon appétit
[Musique]
alors d'où vient le mot rigueur ça vient
du mont français a fuit et la hague est
présenté dans sa peau appartient à la
même famille que l'andouille à
l'andouillette
[Rires]
à promenade pour digérer ces mets
délicats rien de tel que quelques petits
pas de danse traditionnelle le stylet
est formel et gracieux enfin presque
cela s'appelle le country dancing
et stop the one free fight night game
jam changeait pas
voilà
au pub l'ambiance est disons moins
guindé mais plus un bébé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
robert burns ses poèmes le aguicher les
petits pas chasser c'est bien joli mais
finalement on en revient toujours au
même à paris ou ailleurs la seule
question que tout le monde se pose à
propos des écossais c'est
est ce que c'est vrai que les hommes
sont nus sous leur culte oui s'ils sont
de vrais écossais et vous vous êtes un
vrai cossette bien entendu